welcome to get cooking in cloud where we
share the best recipes to apply in your
cloud kitchen I am priyanka and we have
a very special guest I'm Carter Morgan
in this episode we'll be making a
souffle that is a great metaphor because
souffles have a reputation of being
complex but actually very simple to
prepare just like the theme of today's
show migrating monoliths to micro
services based cloud applications we're
not actually making a souffle ha
[Music]
imagine you're an IT professional in
charge of a complex website you need to
modernize imagine this design is a
monolith in it's time to move to the
cloud maybe the way things have been
done is mostly working for you but when
it comes time to upgrade a service or
add a new feature you start running into
problems like future rollouts taking
forever because your monolithic app can
only be deployed once the quarter well
without a recipe it can be hard to know
exactly how to transition your
application in a way that minimizes
risks downtime and customer
dissatisfaction and also money lost
while modernizing your platform by
moving to the cloud and by switching to
micro services involves learning new
tools and new ways of working all of
that can seem overwhelming but those
fears shouldn't stop you for reaping the
benefits of a micro service based cloud
platform you want to modernize your
platform to provide a more nimble and
scalable environment for the individual
features of the site where the features
can be more easily managed and updated
than if they're part of the monolithic
platform running in such an environment
leads to faster improvements well if you
want to just migrate everything at once
that would be a lot of risk involved but
if you were to just migrate feature by
feature you can avoid that large amount
of risk there are three main patterns
for this type of migration to the cloud
lift and shift improve and move and rip
and replace we're going to use a
specific flavor of the rip and replace
pattern where the pattern is implying
incremental eating each feature the
application rather than to the
application as a whole ooh
micro servings over the next few videos
we'll use e-commerce website as an
example because veggies aren't fun no
guardar because many of these are built
with monolithic proprietary tools so
they are really good candidates for this
migration but even if you don't have an
e-commerce site you can apply the
principles that we will cover here to a
wide range of workloads in addition to
this migration pattern we'll show you
two hybrid patterns during the migration
itself the application has a hybrid
architecture where some of the features
are in the cloud and some are still on
premises after the migration is finished
the complete cloud application is hosted
in the cloud but it still interacts with
back-end services that
remain on premises Wow moving to cloud
could be messy well there you have it if
you're looking to migrate your existing
monolithic platform to the cloud you've
gotten a taste of what's in the store
for the rest of this series stay tuned
for the next episode where we will
actually make a souffle
haha know where we will walk through the
migration process but if you are excited
to get on this migration journey with us
then don't forget to Like and subscribe
to our Channel
[Music]